hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the pre-socratic
philosopher Heraclitus from what we can
tell from the fragments that we possess
of his work had a very significant
interest in what we could call the
dynamics of cosmic change that is this
universe that were surrounded by and
that we move within and were a part of
what actually is going on when things
change from one thing to another is
there anything to take some of the other
you know great philosophers of the time
is there anything that can be said to be
the same running through all of this and
you're going to notice as you read
through his text that he makes reference
to several things that we we call
elements the basic building blocks of
the the universe and all the things in
it and the ancient Greeks tended to look
at those in terms of four elements earth
air fire and water but they thought that
you could take those and build up an
entire universe or cosmos of things that
were you know combinations in certain
ways of these and dominated by some and
you know perhaps not even including
others and the ancient Greeks are really
grappling with this and appears that
Heraclitus was as well now
Heraclitus adopts a you could say if
we're on a spectrum from you know
absolute fixity as in Parmenides to
absolute change complete flux nothing
stays the same which is sometimes how
Heraclitus is represented by say for
example Plato and by people who later on
or satirizing him like Lucian of Sam
soda
Heraclitus would actually be not all the
way at the end of the spectrum but a
good way towards that end of universal
flux and I think all of you are probably
familiar if you haven't heard it coming
from Heraclitus you've at least heard
the expression you can't step in the
same river twice what's the explanation
for that because the waters are not the
same the the moment that you step into
the river again things are in flux
things are changing and the element of
water is particularly good for
illustrating that because unlike air you
can actually see it and unlike earth
which more or less stays the same at
least to the naked eye within our
experience although if we use time-lapse
photography we can see that it moves as
well we can see that water is constantly
flowing and fire is kind of like that as
well so is there then anything that is
constant if there isn't then we would
really have a conceptual problem how can
we have words or concepts or whatever
we're going to talk about
representations of a universe that is
totally in flux and largely because of
that reason since there's nothing under
girding it it unpredictable what we
couldn't so the very fact that we have
to use another one of Heraclitus terms a
logos whether in the sense of like the
cosmic logos that it runs everything and
and structures everything or logos just
in the sense of human language speeches
which could be deceptive
the very fact that we have that means
that it's not a complete flux it's not a
total chaos there's something more going
on and so this is when we we want to
look at his his discussions and he talks
about in fragment 30 in the deals
there is something cosmos universe order
we could say that is indeed everlasting
and so here's a translation of an order
was not made by God or human beings so
what does that sing that means that
order is always there cosmos at least is
always there
whatever cosmos means and it's not
dependent on human beings and their
constructions of it although they can
certainly represent it all they want to
nor is it dependent on the gods he says
it is and it always was and is and shall
be an everlasting fire flaring up in
regular measures and dying down in
regular measures well that's a decent
translation what what Heraclitus is
actually saying and he's using this word
ie there which we can translate as
always eternal it always is there always
is this ordering that's going on and
that ordering itself is now here's where
we have a distinctive you could say
approach on Heraclitus is part the
elements are not all on the same level
fire in some sense is the most important
of the elements so we have an
everlasting fire a per eye aids alone in
Greek right so para is is a fire but
this is alone right it's a very
interesting construction here it's not
just saying that it's it's you know by
itself something that is eternal it in a
certain respect is eternity so
there you know and we can't push this
too far I think but we can certainly say
that there's something interesting going
on there then the other thing that's
really key to this is that this fire
however we want to translate this it
flares up it expands it it grows at
Kindles
and it dies out as well so it's not by
itself something that's purely static
something that has its being in the way
that it is once and for all in eternity
instead the very thing that is eternal
is itself you could say expanding and
contracting or becoming more manifest
and becoming less manifest and he says
that it does this in measures Metra in
greek he said well what's measuring it
well we don't actually know but we do
know that it is not random it's not
purely just happening and not happening
or anything like that so that's a really
key idea another passage that I think is
really central and reinforcing this is
fragment 38 in the deals where he tells
us that fire is a medium of exchange
onto moy be something that we can give
in place of another thing and it's a
medium of exchange for everything Ponta
maybe even including itself and we think
this through and how is it a medium of
exchange it is a medium of exchange in
the same way he's using an analogy here
that gold is a medium of exchange for
all goods all things that we might want
and again we could think well as gold
also a medium of exchange for itself is
there a measure to this so fire is what
not only you could say structure is
everything and underlies everything but
it's also what everything it can
be exchanged for in some ways so this is
a good place then to talk about the
cosmic processes as Heraclitus
represents them and I think we have to
be very careful here not to over read
these passages and to read too much of
our own ideas into them we have the
passages that we have and they are quite
tantalizing in that they show us that
there's at least some sort of
rudimentary cosmic process that
Heraclitus was interested in theorizing
and then representing and teaching us
about but we don't actually know too
much about how it works we can only
glimpse portions of it and presumably
his book on nature would have had a lot
more of this the testimonies that are
provided by other authors or they say
well Heraclitus and his followers taught
this we don't know whether that's
actually the case or not so I just want
to stick to what we actually have is as
fragments so in one of them in fragment
31 he tells us that there's this process
of you could say movement from one thing
to another he calls it the turning
points of fire first see now it's
interesting he doesn't say water right
he says see the last shot that's the the
Greek word for the you know the body of
water that they were encountering in the
while the Black Sea and the
Mediterranean and the Aegean and all of
that and then that see whatever this
cosmic principle of sea is it itself is
divided into two things earth and he
says by half actually so he uses the
word Hemi there earth gay right
which doesn't just mean dirt but really
all the solid things like stone and all
that that we're encountering and then
this word that's hard to translate
Prester right which could mean like here
it's translated
lightning but it's often translated as
the thunderbolt which is also similar
some translations of it have it being a
waterspout or in a water cyclone tied
together with lightning so we don't
really know what he had in mind other
than the fact that there's this process
where fire is becoming sea which is
becoming earth and this other thing and
he goes on and he says sea drains off
and is measured into the same principle
as before it became earth so again we
see that we have a kind of measuring
process going on here it's not just
stupid or you know brute we could say
there there's a structure to what's
happening even more tantalizing are the
passages where he talks about one thing
the life of one thing being the death of
another thing and this is where
sometimes the translations get a little
wonky if we look at the actual deals
fragments that are gathered together
about this the ones that involve fire
there's several of them and it's not
always exactly the same ordering but but
the basic idea is that one thing is the
death of another so you know let's take
a look at one of these in translation
just to give you an idea of what's going
on here here he's talking about soul's
death for souls is the birth of water
death for water is the birth of Earth
Earth is the source of water water is
the source of soul this is coming from
Clement so you know we're not quite sure
how much we could trust this although
climate is pretty reliable and here
we're talking about death Thanatos and
birth kanessa right but in other cases
it's same life right the life of you
know fire for example is the death of
air or the life of Earth is the death of
water and so there's you know again if
we go back to this things are being
exchanged for each other put in place of
each other now it seems like fire has a
less
privileged position and maybe we
actually although there's nothing in the
text to to say that this is the case but
maybe speculatively we need to say that
fire has an unusual position in that
it's not just fire the element but also
you know fire in the sense of this this
cosmic structuring thing again we can't
push that very far without going you
know beyond the text itself another
place he talks about the qualities and
that is worth looking at so what do we
mean by the qualities the things that
the ancient Greeks saw this for element
theory as being connected with here's
the past such cool things become warm
warm things cool down moist things dry
out parched things become damp and so we
have a cosmic process of going back and
forth from these four basic qualities
warmth and coolness on the one side
wetness and dryness on the other side
well it turns out that these are
actually in ancient Greek cosmogony
and people other than Heraclitus tied in
with earth air fire water right so we
think we can probably read in there that
Heraclitus thought more or less the same
and he's not reducing everything to
these properties but they certainly are
things that are constantly changing
right the last thing that I think is
particularly important and this is in
this is in passage 66 right he talks
about fire as approaching that balzone
literally means you sort of like walking
up on and so fire itself is coming
closer to other things
he uses the word Ponte there actually
everything and then it does two things
by virtue of being close
it judges clean a that's a really easy
term to translate right it's the word
that we get critic from judging means to
like render a judgment on good or bad
you know what kind of thing it is Karina
sometimes it means to distinguish things
apart from each other and that he says
something right after that and it grasps
everything now the the term there is
cattle apes a tie right which in Greek
it's coming from Cathy lamb Bono kata is
downward but it can also be an
intensifying word lamb bono is to grasp
I'm grasping my arm right now I'm
gripping it right and it gets used very
early on for a number of things that are
not physical but are more cognitive or
more adversarial you can grasp something
by like occupying it right you can take
it but you can also wrap your mind
around it so fire in this case is doing
some things that you know we typically
would associate with human beings or for
ancient Greeks with gods you know
because gods are also rational beings
just higher than us fire itself is able
to judge and to mentally grasp mentally
wrap it's I guess it's the tongues of
fire around whatever this is supposed to
be
and here we reach sort of the limits of
our understanding of Heraclitus how does
fire do that he doesn't explain he
simply asserts that it does but I think
that we should see that in terms of this
everlasting fire that is flaring out and
dying out in measures and the fire
that's a medium of everything that fire
appears to be itself conscious in a way
that perhaps transcends us or includes
our consciousness within it and this is
why quite often although Heraclitus
doesn't say the fire is the logos it's
very tempting for us to say that in
interpreting him
what he means by fire and what he means
by logos are indeed the same basic thing
but here we're looking at how fire is
involved as an element among the
elements but also structuring and
guiding them in terms of these cosmic
processes
you